always like looking up and seeing that
mike floria from pro football talk live
is joining us here
busy morning here mike now you guys
broke the story on pro football talk
live that
the jets have been sent home players and
coaches
and the cardinals aren't sure what's
going on and when they fly in so
how long does the nfl wait to make a
decision or are we looking at another
tuesday night game well here's what's
going on dan they're retesting the
player who tested positive it's a
presumptive
positive it could be a false positive
which is odd because
i don't remember the nba or the nhl
having any false positives whatsoever
but they are retesting the player
they sent the players and coaches home
out of an abundance of caution
they'll know more later in the day
basically you get the sample you send it
to the lab for the test
you wait for the result once the sample
gets there it doesn't take all that long
to turn it around
then they'll know what they're going to
do but until then they're losing a work
day friday's not the most important work
day of the week
but they're still losing a work day in
advance of their game against the
arizona cardinals so i i don't know what
happens at this point
if it comes back as a confirmed positive
that obviously complicates things if
it's a negative
then they move forward presumably on
sunday although i don't know maybe we're
going for a triple header
on monday the way things have been going
lately and then the patriots
you know i just asked mclovin is cam
newton playing in this game against
denver
is stefan gilmore playing here we are
friday and
have they been given clearance what you
need to have if you're asymptomatic
five days and two negative tests at
least 24 hours apart they believe cam
newton will be able to play
on monday night when they face the
broncos now stefan gilmore
tested positive on tuesday so the
timeline for him
is tighter you're talking about a
six-day window if he's asymptomatic and
if the virus
clears his body to the point where he
can have two negative tests but
you know dan what this patriot situation
underscores and
i saw the reporting today and it's every
morning between 7 30 and 8 o'clock
eastern it's like the clarence beaks
crop report
and you'll see 10 different reporters
all reporting based on the same unnamed
source whether there's negatives or
positives
just because the patriots are all
negative today doesn't mean they're out
of the woods because of the incubation
period that's the one thing that keeps
getting lost in this
someone could have been exposed to the
virus based on contact with stephon
gilmour
on monday night in kansas city in that
cramped locker room that they have there
on the flight home where they had the
two planes the guys who did have close
contact with cam newton and those who
didn't
and gilmore was on the plane with the
guys who did and then you've got an
incubation period that could hit
tomorrow sunday monday with another
positive so
every day that the news comes back clean
that isn't time to exhale it's just
exhale for now until tomorrow when we
get the next round of tests
is there a contingency plan on pausing
this season
where maybe a two week or three week
window and and and maybe
bubblizing these teams in hotels i i
don't know how drastic
how strict the nfl can or would get
i i think that those two options
don't have to happen together you don't
have to pause the season if you're going
to have home market bubbles which i've
been saying for well over a week now
they need to do i mean what's happened
is the nfl basically has had the bullet
graze its
ear and they've decided to keep going
full speed ahead
they got lucky with the titans although
i don't know that i would call it lucky
if they don't play their game
this week and they will have missed two
games because the makeup
of bills at titans is going to be a lot
harder to pull off
than steelers at titans but at some
point they've just got to hit that
button and say
we are putting everyone in a hotel you
know the nfl's attitude is
basically we're going to have people who
test positive if you follow our
protocols
it won't spread which i don't really buy
and i'm told that when they had a
conference call on monday dr
sills the chief medical officer was
pushing the idea that the nfl's approach
is actually better
than what a home market bubble would be
or a regional bubble would be and people
just aren't buying that it's not better
you can't just accept oh well we're
going to send 170 people home
from every team every night coaches
players essential personnel
they each have their own story as to
what they do where they go who they
interact with
and we just say well you know some of
them are going to be positive from time
to time we'll just deal with it
it's better to put everybody in a hotel
lock it down
get everyone sign on for it if they're
going to opt out give another chance to
opt out
that's what they should do and i feel
like they're eventually going to do it
they're just going to wait a little bit
longer until there's an incident worse
than what we've seen in tennessee
and there's been this talk and you know
my source said that you know
he when he listens to the show he goes
people keep saying well just move uh
the season back a couple of weeks and he
just says remind people that not
everybody
has missed games so tennessee if they
miss
two games let's say then i do i have an
extra
two weeks before i start the playoffs
just to accommodate the tennessee titans
at what point does the nfl say to a team
you're going to forfeit a game well
you've you've raised two very good
points there
let me address the scheduling realities
first
i was on with chris mad dog russo
earlier this week and he had an idea
that
pissed me off because it's one of those
things i wish i
thought of it instead of just tacking a
week of games onto the end of the season
and then having the teams that are in
the first round
buy there's only two this year one in
each conference go three weeks between
games
you just take week 17 as is make it week
18
play the makeup games week 17 however
many there need to be now some teams may
need more than one which would be a
problem
but always make the last weekend of the
regular season
whatever your week 17 currently is that
crescendo that we love every year where
everyone plays on the same day
and all the playoffs are determined and
then no one goes three weeks between
games
on the back end i like that as to
forfeits here's the problem
two problems for the nfl one if you
start forfeiting games
you have to start cutting checks back to
the networks they're not going to pay
for games they're not going to pay
to come on and say the bills have beaten
the titans two to nothing
all right secondly because that's in the
rulebook if there's a forfeit final
score two nothing
second thing the players have agreed not
to be paid for games that are suspended
or
cancelled they haven't agreed to not be
paid for games that are forfeited
that creates an issue between the league
and the union because if you forfeit a
game
well if this game between the bills and
titans gets forfeited because the titans
have just been a mess
over the past two weeks the bill's
players do you deprive them of their
game check
why should why should they not get paid
they're ready to go
they should get the titans paycheck the
titans should pay this the titans should
pay the bills payroll that week that's
part of that should be part of the
penalty if that ever happens
when you saw brady put up four fingers
last night
wasn't he referring to the fact that
patrick mahomes was the fourth
player on the nfl's top 100 list is that
maybe that's what it was
um look hey it when when your two
biggest selling points
are your brains and your experience and
you have the brian hoyer moment it's a
perfect book end
brian hoyer thinks he's got a time out
he does the chris webber thing on monday
night and then you turn around and tom
brady
thinks he still has another down which
means he wouldn't have thrown the ball
down the field on what was
fourth and five unless he was trying to
pull a jedi mind trick on the officials
which would have been awesome if that's
what he was trying to do
that what was it missouri colorado
colorado the fifth down game right if he
was trying to pull that off great but
based on the way everybody talked about
it after the game uh no
tom just forgot it was fourth down which
is stunning for any starting quarterback
but especially stunning for what what
was more surprising
that brady didn't know his fourth down
or bruce arians after the game said yes
tom knew it was fourth down
well i think bruce learned after calling
brady out repeatedly after the week one
game that
you really don't want to do that with
tom brady
and so he was just throwing him a little
lifeline there surely he knew
uh that well no he didn't know and
aryans knows he didn't know
but there's nothing to be gained by
throwing tom brady under the bus
i mean the reality is yeah that was the
final moment that
that things fell apart but my god if the
buccaneers could have at least
blocked a little bit last night it never
would have come to that
fewer flags the first month last night
was
didn't follow the company line uh party
line but is this a directive do you
think from the nfl to the officials of
let's let's be a little looser here and
and you know not be the story
well yeah and that's what walt anderson
the new supervisor of officials told nfl
media
week two he didn't put it in those terms
but he said
the focal point is clear and obvious
violations which means
there's going to be some stuff you can
get away with now then the coaches
adjust to the things you can get away
with
last night some of the holding fouls
looked like the the fouls that
would be called if you're not looking
for clear and obvious so you know it's
always a moving target peter king made
that point today on pft live
that the officiating changes every year
and it's unfortunate it should always be
the same standard
but the end result has been get some of
these college style exciting 35 32 41 38
games i like that now last night's game
was exciting
20 to 19 but it didn't have the offense
that we've gotten accustomed to
and so it's always going to adjust it's
always going to adapt
and there's always going to be a
directive to the officials as to how the
league wants games officiated that's
just part of the sport
thank you mike have a great weekend
thanks dan see pal that's mike florio
pro football talk live co-host and
they broke the news that the jets have
gone home because
they presumptive positive tests with one
of their players who are going to retest